a song you're going to do from the new
album is called right on time
the album is called in the silent days
yeah and uh first of all i should bring
up i don't even know how the association
happens but the video was made by
courtney cox from friends
yeah
i mean how did that happen i met her
through uh a friend um uh miriam
malagpur who styles courtney and styles
me
um which there couldn't be anything
similar about our style but
i got invited around to her house and we
just hit it off like people do sometimes
wow
and then she ended up
yeah she's a pretty damn good musician
right yeah she's really good she's got a
really good sense of rhythm courtney
heard the song
and she basically just acted out this
video for me she was the one she was she
acted it she did all the things
and
and she's like because i think this song
is about
you know for me it's about these
invisible visible obstacles that you put
in front of yourself and they can be
huge it can be as big as the elements as
big as fire and and
water
but they're not really there
and so she had this idea of breaking
through this invisible glass and i just
loved it the song is beautiful so you
guys ready to perform this you feel uh
all set this is from the new album
[Music]
come
back now
even if you call
me out
you might be
angry now
of course you are
i'm
scared too
didn't mean to take it out
on you
i know i
always do
you're the strongest person in
the room
turn
back time
help me to rewind and we can
find
ourselves again
it's not too late
either way
i lose you in these silent days it
wasn't right
but it was right
on
time
don't
look down
i can feel it when your heart
starts pounding it's beyond
your control
[Music]
[Applause]
back i did what i had to do
it's not too late
[Music]
i lose you in these
it wasn't right
but it was right
on
time
[Music]
it's not too late
either way
i
it lose
right
but it was right
on
time
[Music]
holy moly well i got this
first of all you guys i mean that's a
home run that song's a home run no
yes
i don't even know how you hit those
notes my chills have chills it's really
remarkable
you